Lannister Baratheon stop
Tyrel they will just spokes on a wheel
this one's on top then that one's on top
and on and on it spins crushing those on
the ground
[Applause]
I'm not going to stop the wheel
I'm going to break the wheel Stannis
Baratheon has an army at Castle black it
means to take the north this is the time
and I will risk everything winter is
coming
we know what's coming with it we can
learn to live with the wildlands
we can add them to the army of the death
you have a few we are the many
we serve the gods and the gods demand
justice this city
so the rats have nowhere left to hide
I am a queen not a butcher
although us rather butchers don't meet